we need a big director element and Tim
was always at the top of our list and
everybody's like Tim Burton's never done
television and you know I started in
sales out of college I said well if you
don't ask the answers no so we got it to
uh Tim's agent and then we thought okay
it's we may never hear from you usually
as you know it's actus you're an actor
like you send active scripts you never
hear back before it takes eight weeks to
get back and then they pause yeah it's
like oh he finally write it it's a pass
it's like it's just it's throwing things
into the ethers it's like just it's
never never happens you never hear back
never hear it and then four days later
we heard back Tim read the script he
loved it he wants to get on a on a call
with you to talk about it and Mike
Simpsons is his agent who's a huge agent
over at wme's Quentin Tarantino and and
we said oh great well he set up a zoom
or something he goes no I'm gonna send
you Tim's number and you can FaceTime
him tomorrow because he lives he lives
in England so we did and it was like a
classic where was your mom has this this
place in near Oxford this beautiful like
country estate and the garden is filled
with these life-sized dinosaur like
statues so he's standing there in his
dinosaur Garden talking to us on his on
his and losing reception it was just
like the most surreal moving around
we're like we can't believe we're
talking and he's like I love this script
he goes like are you nervous of course
because it's he's Tim Burton yeah so
you're just going like and we have a
number and I had never done a FaceTime
before so I was like up early practicing
it with my kids going like oh if I put
this I have to put two numbers in this
thing how do I do it
four I don't know what the hell it is
right right so we did it and he's like I
I love the script I felt like you were
in my head like it it all I would have
dated Wednesday Adams in high school and
we were like oh my God like it was
amazing we're like great you know so we
have this because so you know we're like
do you want it would you like to direct
the pilot because I want to direct all
of them he goes do you have more and
then so he he ended up doing four of the
eight so you would have done more he
would have done all of them